i want to talk about a story in which a
uh daughter whose dad recently died of
covid
uh went on cnn
and at least partially blamed fox news
propagandist tucker carlson for his role
in her dad's covet death uh her dad
falling for misinformation including the
misinformation he consumed from tucker
carlson and there's sort of like
three stories here one is
to what degree if any
does tucker or do other media people
uh bear responsibility for these deaths
number two is there something that feels
a little bit off or exploitative about
these types of interviews with the
surviving family members and then number
three something a bunch of people
emailed me about which is could there
ever be like a legal responsibility
for someone in the media
as a result of people that die thanks to
having followed or fallen for that
misinformation so to set the stage just
briefly
this article outlines what happened here
daughter blames tucker carlson's
misinformation for playing a role in
dad's coveted death the 45 year old
father of two
had no underlying health conditions a
washington woman whose father died of
the coronavirus said he was hesitant to
get vaccinated because of misinformation
he heard in right wing media and
specifically cited fox news host tucker
carlson katie lane said her father 45
year old boeing designer patrick lane
wasn't on the far right politically
we'll get to that when asked what
specifically made her father refuse the
shot the 20 year old cited tucker
carlson
um
katie said her father was waiting for
full fda approval before getting the
shot and this is interesting but by the
time that happened he was already sick
one of his last comments was he wished
he had been vaccinated and there have
been many many people saying i'm just
waiting for that full approval that full
approval has come and gone and many
still not interested in getting
vaccinated for patrick lane it was too
late he was too he was already sick he
couldn't get vaccinated let's listen to
some of the interview and then discuss
why was he so hesitant to get vaccinated
katie
uh
there there's multiple reasons i think
uh one of which was
some of the media that he ingested he
wasn't by any means
far right he was right in the middle and
he consumed media from both sides
and just some of the misinformation on
one of those sides
made him hesitant so he was going to
wait for fda approval but by the time
that pfizer had been approved it was
already too late
wiser got the full fda approval and your
father was already sick
evan
talk to me
about
your final goodbye to your father did
you have a chance
to spend any real time with him so this
is the part that to me is starting to
feel a little bit exploitative i've seen
a bunch of interviews like this and and
there's a disaster porn aspect to it
i'm not feeling fully comfortable with
it including the desire to figure out
what were the last words and you'll see
that at a point soon
john berman actually asks were those his
last words and i think it's it's the
daughter says well those were his last
words to my stepmom or something like
that but there's there's something
that's starting to almost get like
salacious about these interviews and i
don't know that i'm loving it
not really i was already
staying at another house and he was just
coming by to pick something up and
he didn't even want to get too close
because he was too worried about getting
me sick so i didn't even get to hug him
before he left and then
before i knew he was gone
you guys are vaccinated now evan you
know what was the message ultimately
that your father wanted to spread about
vaccines
he wasn't
anti-vaccine he was just hesitant and
i
now that you know pfizer's been fda
approved i don't think he would have
anything wrong with telling people to
get that vaccine he uh his final words
to my stepmom on a facetime call was
that
he wishes he wished that he was
vaccinated
those were his final words
uh to my stepmom uh the last call that
she had with him he said that he wished
that he was vaccinated
so like
what are people with me does this feel
somewhat exploitative like i i mean if
maybe if the point is just to convince
people to get vaccinated maybe this is
effective i i just don't know i'm not
sure
and katie you said from
one media source in particular he was
getting misinformed or he was getting
information that led him to be hesitant
on vaccines who i mean who was he
listening to
uh he he watched some tucker carlson
videos on youtube
uh
and some of those videos involved
some misinformation about vaccines and i
believe that that played a role
evan what do you want people to remember
so oh where did where to even start
right um i got an email asking more or
less about legal liability like if you
can demonstrate that this guy wasn't
vaccinated because of tucker carlson
could there be legal liability no
absolutely not i mean you even if in
theory so let's see where there's
multiple reasons as to why not first of
all
how do you
you'd have to demonstrate that number
one were it not only for tucker carlson
this man would have been vaccinated
the vaccine is not 100 effective at
preventing death it's very effective at
preventing death but not 100 100 so you
could not even prove that had this
particular person been vaccinated
they would not have died but moreover
you know fox news has already argued
legally
that tucker carlson's show is
entertainment
uh that no reasonable person would would
interpret what tucker says as fact that
it's performative that it's
entertainment
and also there are so many instances and
so many media outlets where
disinformation is being spread whether
it's called entertainment or news
there's no there's not going to be it
would never succeed to try to hold
tucker carlson legally liable for this
so
i guess the questions are
given that it's undeniable that the
misinformation
does play a role in people not getting
vaccinated
what could be done what should be done
from a legal standpoint if anything or
is it just a matter of this is just
speech and certainly platforms can
regulate it if they want facebook can
say
we will police disinformation content
about vaccines
but that's not a legal issue it's not
illegal it's just facebook says well
we're not going to allow it on our
platform which is their right to do
and then lastly
how are people feeling about these types
of segments in general the
the what were the last words and and
this type of thing
is there an exploitative aspect to it
is is there an exploitative aspect
that's acceptable if the goal is to
convince people to get vaccinated
let me know what you think
let's be honest most healthy snack bars
are not exciting like my live streams
and that's why you should check out our
sponsor monk pack monk pack keto nut and
seed bars
are sweet and delicious soft and chewy
with a big satisfying crunch but each
bar has just one gram of sugar two to
three net carbs and just 150 calories so
it's great for someone on a keto or low
carb diet or even if you just want a
tasty sweet snack without the sugar
monk pack keto nut and seed bars come in
great flavors like sea salt dark
chocolate
caramel sea salt or caramel you choose
and peanut butter dark chocolate i
always have a box of these ready to go
in my pantry
which is easy when you do the optional
monthly subscription which also saves
you 10
if you have a sweet tooth this is the
way to indulge without the guilt whether
it's for breakfast or in the car or
after a workout go to monkpack.com the
link is under this video and you'll save
20 percent when you use code pacman at
checkout